kyle hendricks has been so good over the
course of his last 10 start as the
bullpen has gotten taxed they really
needed kyle hendricks to give them
innings
right field hayward towards the line
jason
[Applause]
man
alfonso marquez
you know the rest of the crew gonna crew
gonna get together and they're gonna
decide whether that was fan interference
let's see here
yeah it is
yeah and then the question is was it a
catchable ball for jason hayward
so i think jason's pulling up a tiny bit
because the guy's reaching and they just
called him back that didn't take long a
little conversation
so that's good
here we go again catch this one
[Applause]
nobody sees it
obviously he was deakin the whole time
and rizzo was running all the way from
first land if y'all are having problems
i'll take it all hands on deck cardinals
have wade leblanc making the start 123
career starts but none of them have been
at wrigley
contreras takes a walk to lead it off
three and two now on wisdom man at first
nobody out they off hit
that one ripped left field o'neal coming
out and smothers it on a bounce
contreras big turn but it's a base hit
so he was just able to put that one down
in front
of the gold glover tyler o'neill
[Music]
into left field buy as a base hit and
they'll hold up
wilson contreras as o'neill fires a
strike to the dish
marissnik back in the box with a two
ball two-strike count bases loaded the
pitch swinging and a miss struck him out
jack peterson comes up now lefty against
lefty with the bases loaded in two outs
so now there are two down lefty against
lefty jack peterson steps in
that one falling coming on carlson and
he can't make the play
in the score contreras wisdom here comes
baez and it's three nothing cups the
base is clear on a little floater to
right and javi comes in just in time to
beat the throw to put up that first
inning field roll
six for his last 14.
and nolan
to your point jimmy shoots it the other
way
and a base hit and now the tying run
will come to the plate in tyler o'neill
tyler o'neal a chance to tie this game
don't make an out doesn't matter how you
get on don't make an out
base hit by o'neal he'll stop it first
that'll score a run cardinals get on the
board dylan carlson scores and that
makes it now a 3-1 game molina a chance
to get the cardinals one step closer
out to center and a base head
orinato will score five straight
swinging on the first pitch
here in the third and with that it's a
one run game two runners on and here
come the cardinals edmond a switch
hitter batting left-handed the 1-1
fly ball shallow left center baya's
going out peterson in the left fielder
will make the catch and that ends the
enemy
check swing bounder back to the mound
hendricks will throw out vader that's
out number one
hendricks ready wants kicks 3-2
swing and a miss struck him out
and kyle gets a 1-2-3 for the first time
today
and we have a cardinal debut it's luis
garcia who's pitching 326 career games
in the big leagues
98 miles an hour up and in
he's shaking his head and it's just
scary
pj manville just looking at him talking
to him yeah
i'm being a little bit of shock that's
that's what it seemed as though
there was that reaction
3-1 pitch from garcia
oh sosa knocks it down and they'll get
the lead man on a hard hit ball
small lead wisdom at first
and now the other way that is a base hit
so rizzo
able to slice one to left two on one out
ian half's gonna get a chance as he hits
for jake mariznick two
around third and then to score is wisdom
half off the bench
and he delivers 4-2
well done in half like rizzo before him
he goes the other way
center field that'll fall for a hit
so hayward a one out knock
fastball and he swung on it missed it
and a strikeout for miller
we ended the sixth
hayward again and sliding into your
picture to make the grab and a
spectacular diving catch against the
phillies the other night and here he
comes again gold glove
closing ground in a hurry
the lead at second by bader the pitch
fly ball left field shallow playable
peterson there he's got it
no runs for st lou we go to the bottom
of the sixth inning cubs four cardinals
and now the time run at the plate as the
tying run will come to the plate david
ross out of the dugout and will go
to the bullpen at his lefty and his
righty up hendricks another outstanding
effort here today
and he gets a great hand
mr dependable kyle hendricks cubs lead
new pitcher coming in again ryan tupero
will take over
[Applause]
on the ground as nico horner will
collect it and throw it to first and
that
ends the inning
here's the payoff
hap takes low and outside ball four lead
off walk
3-2
inside he'll take his base to a board
[Applause]
cabrera's pitch inside and hayward gets
hit
and that hurt
it hit him in the arm he never fell down
but that could not have felt good at all
no command whatsoever sprang it all over
the place and mike chillz has seen
enough
to watch and hit batter junior fernandez
hadn't pitched in nine days then
appeared in the finale against san
francisco chris bryant climbs in the
cubs all-star
and the
[Applause]
here comes hayward
kb off the bench
[Applause]
second base is clearing double of the
day for the cubs
fernandez with two outs and a man at
second field
and that is crushed out towards left
center field heading towards the
bleachers and gone
number 12 patrick wisdom
and it is 9-2 a towering homer
that he deposits into the bleachers and
left
it to the right side
and
nobody
out
that's actually in a
in a close game
he's about a half a step off of making a
really nice play 3-0 on harrison boehner
[Applause]
and the bases are loaded
so pitch and change here at wrigley top
eight
and the cubs enjoying a 9-2 lead here
comes the sheriff
cubs on top nine to two chafin comes
back
strike three call
carpenter didn't like it
chaffin gets the strikeout
cardinals leave the maximum
like the tortoise
can't make the play
and jack sprinting for second and he's
in there
and hayward will line one toward left
center field base hit another run is in
cubs lead 10-2
hayward stood right in there against the
left-hander and hammer to base it in the
left center
and a base hit into center carlson will
score and that'll make it 10-3
goldschmidt drives in his 48th of the
year
now paul de young coming to bet
into deep right into the basket it's a
home run opposite way paul de young
and that makes it 10-5 with an opposite
field home run
he let that ball get so deep and stayed
on it
you want to see the couch step on the
gas
do it right there ryan fires in a strike
and that's the ball game comes with 10-5
the final